men's dating pool never [ __ ] shrinks
it literally never shrinks you can just
keep dating we are dating pull shrinks
as we get older that's why i'm just like
really you get to do this too you get to
have everything why why
do you think it's a misconception
it's only for a small percentage of men
that the dating pool doesn't decrease
most guys they hit their peak in high
school or college and then when they're
in their 30s they're fat they're broke
or they're married whatever it's only a
very small percentage of men like uh
that you know are high value man
whatever you want to call it that for
whom the pool does not where's that
statistic most men peak in high school i
do not think so well think about it get
hotter and hotter and hotter
there's some actually
you're actually both kind of right
because
peaking in high school is a little
aggressive however you see what you're
saying
that
um for a certain percentage like 20 of
men and it might even be closer to 10 of
men but a smaller percentage of men get
eighty percent of the women yeah okay
like we've seen these stats before so
like
all women want this ex you know a high
value man is what they talk about okay
actually all right let me throw myself
under the bus here for a second i went
on a date recently lovely girl won't
name her name went on a date
and she says um you know what are you
looking for so i'm 41 right
i said you know something somewhat
serious at this point not you know and
she goes well um what age girls do you
typically date
and i actually had to think about it for
a second i said
i don't know if i've ever dated a girl
in her 30s
is that nuts
when i was 21 i dated a 20 year old when
i was 25 i dated a 22 year old when i
was 30 i dated a 24 year old when i was
36 i dated a 23 year old and now that
i'm 40 i'm hanging out with 25 year olds
one girl the one girl i dated who was in
her 30s was the most immature girl i've
ever dated and i told her i go how do
you expect me to actually take you
seriously when you're a [ __ ] child
so to a certain extent you know like the
matthew mcconaughey thing right i get
old you know i get older and they say
the same age all right all right all
right this that can happen and leo but
and i'm just being you know
it's because i've got my [ __ ] together
like i still you know and because you
can't stay in shape i've got money i'm
successful high value man by the odds
not every guy can do that so that's kind
of to your point that like a lot of guys
like my high school buddies they're like
bro i would wish to be like you 40
single mama i'm like yeah but you're
you've let yourself go you don't give a
[ __ ] you don't take care of yourself
anymore it's it's different for a
certain sect of of guys than for most
guys most guys are most guys right
you're part of a very small percentage
of men
explain that like most guys do not
follow that path most guys they get a
medial job after high school they get
married they let themselves go maybe
when they're 40 they're divorced they're
fat they're broke i think being in miami
has [ __ ] up my idea of this country
completely i've grown up here i don't
know i went to i went to orlando this
weekend like good orlando i was like oh
my god it's like all of the pretty
people in the country just filtered down
to miami because you look at like every
single person in orlando and everyone's
just looks normal it's just normal i'm
not going in like on a drink were you
running around disney world or were you
running around i wasn't at disney world
but by the way because i don't want to
get miami she lives in la it's the same
thing there new york to a certain degree
because women can't rely on their looks
as much as they do in miami and la as
they do in new york because [ __ ]
rent's expensive not that it's not
expensive over here you got some bills
to pay but i mean what's your what's
your perspective on all this about men
getting older and women you know
losing their sexual market value over
time i think it just depends case by
case
right you're an anomaly are you 40 yet
or not i'm yeah i'm 40. all right let's
just call this bait of spades you're 40
and higher
real hard not to cough right now i'm
still [ __ ] nervous as [ __ ] you're 40
and hot nicki most 40 year olds that's
it she's getting nervous she's calling
here's most 40 year olds don't look as
good as you i i also
think that like what you said some
women let themselves go most women my
age are definitely divorced with two
three four kids
right looking for like whatever they're
looking for and
they
don't find like i just
they don't find the guy that maybe like
they want because of all the baggage
they have right and those divorce men
are looking at the 20 30 pool not the 40
right right that's what i'm saying like
that as you get older for women our
options dwindle
well they dwindle to some extent but the
sexual marketplace is so skewed in the
favor of women i'm not saying that
because i'm like pissed about something
i just is what it is we did a tinder
experiment we took a male model who's
like a really good looking guy like just
by any standard he got 140 matches on
tinder in 24 hours we took a grossly
obese girl who's like
really fat by any standard she got 500
matches in 24 hours so that shows you
that a really fat girl will do
significantly better than a really good
looking guy so the marketplace is just
so skewed when we're talking about sex
for one night on tinder sure but we're
talking about relationships
yeah men will always have more success
with relationships women will have more
success with sex is that fair to say
because most women want to be in
relationships so they end up settling
with guys who are maybe
how often do you see like an amazingly
attractive man with a mediocre girl
it's usually the reverse because women
eventually want to be in a relationship
and men want to have sex yeah well the
famous quote is that the man must attain
the woman but the woman must retain the
math but it's a thing i know you're
rolling your eyes over there
because you're doing guys are doing a
lot of attaining of you over there amber
but are you retaining
sorry were you just calling me a slide
that was a backhanded compliment
but am i retaining them
no
but you think you're sleeping with them
too soon
um i don't know i've done this
experiment in different ways i think men
and um
i think men in miami are like on this
like uh what's this called slot machine
slot machine [ __ ] machine machine boom
use that in your comedy right because
there's just you there's just try again
you have it you're great great try again
and then each girl comes up it's like if
you look at sometimes i just go look at
the dating apps from the male
perspective i'm like geez these are the
amount of girls that i'm i'm competing
with and again if you're not looking to
settle down you could just keep going
why not that's true so but if you move
out of miami you'll have probably way
better success oh i know it
not in l.a
don't go no why do you say not in la
la's one of the worst places to find a
guy
like
just egotistical
uh everybody wants to be an actor they
think they're bigger than what they are
horrible credit scores and you're using
people horrible credit scores that's
right up there on the list uh five guys
driving expensive car you know five guys
driving expensive cars like sharing a
two-bedroom apartment like [ __ ] like
that you're saying that five guys are
splitting splitting the two-bedroom you
know apartment but just so they can
drive
no but they each have a nice car just so
they can get the girls like it's it's
like it's just such a fake
city
i find that it is [ __ ] fake as [ __ ]
so i've always dated a guy out of l.a
never in a well one guy was in l.a well
you live in l.a what do you mean live
data guy like i've always like met them
like
i went to vegas and met a guy in vegas
started dating him you know he was in
nashville like stuff like that like
i feel like is vegas any better meeting
a guy in vegas i i i did
that's literally where the slot machine
said um i'm just saying like it's i feel
like it's really hard to find a good man
in l.a and maybe that's just my
experience but like i talk to girls and
they feel the same way it's hard to find
a guy
in l.a i want to hear more of the advice
of why
we're going to go where's the prime city
to find a guy what would you say
somewhere in the south like uh carolinas
or virginia like a nice southern or
midwestern guy yeah and those guys
wouldn't be
cheating guys uh less likely there's
obviously no guarantee because there's
less options
yeah think i always say if i lived in a
city in the midwest i've been married
with kids already done i mean to your
point i'm in miami it's like all right
i'm not with this girl we broke up all
right what hot girl am i hanging out
with next it's just it's very accessible
and same with a lot of these cities so
if you like that clip click right here
to watch another or if you want to watch
the entire saucecast click right here
[Music]